die aktuellen zahlen zur corona krise 23
1449 neue krone infektionen sind
gemeldet worden in den letzten 24
stunden damit liegt der wert heute 6 140
fälle über dem wert vom letzten freitag
ja damit nichts mit fallenden zahlen am
ende der woche die zahl der ansteckung
bleibt trotz des teils locker und auf
einem hohen niveau und das kurz vor den
lockerungen zu weihnachten unabhängig
davon möchte aber die bundesregierung
weiterhin an den lockerungen festhalten
das sagte heute der regierungssprecher
steffen seibert in berlin
und schauen wir einmal auf die hotspots
und da sehen wir mittlerweile
konzentriert sich das virus vor allem
auf den osten und den süden des landes
hier dunkel eingefärbt die
insolvenzzahlen und deshalb soll da auch
weiter durchgezogen werden was die
beschränkungen betrifft das hat heute
noch mal gesundheitsminister jens spahn
gesagt und appelliert und auch
zusätzliche verschärfungen für örtliche
lagen beispielsweise wie die zentren
passau oder hildburghausen dort die
inzidenz zahl immer noch hoch ins spiel
gebracht zuvor hatte ja bayerns
ministerpräsident markus söder und
sachsens landeschef michael kretschmer
wegen sehr hohen infektionszahlen in
ihren bundesländern härtere maßnahmen
angedroht baden württemberg hat ja erst
gestern für corona hotspots nächtliche
ausgangssperren eingeführt schauen wir
auf die intensivbetten ja da gibt es
mittlerweile eine schlechte nachricht
die schwelle von 4000 ist überschritten
worden heute meldete die deutsche
interdisziplinäre vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin 4011
menschen die intensivmedizinisch
behandelt werden und unter corona leiden
das sind 31 mehr als am vortag die
angegebene zahl der freien
intensivbetten in deutschland ist er in
den vergangenen wochen deutlich
und sie liegt derzeit ohne
notfallreserve bei 5000 dieser
entwicklung kam zustande weil man erst
tatsächlich nur freie betten gemeldet
hat und nicht etwa betten die
betriebsbereit sind so heißt es also für
die auch pflegepersonal zur verfügung
steht und wir haben es ja heute auch
schon besprochen das pflegepersonal ist
der flaschenhals sprechen wir noch über
eine traurige zahl 432 so viele neue
todesfälle gab es innerhalb von 24
stunden das ist der dritthöchste wert
seit beginn der pandemie ja und deshalb
sprach jens spahn auch nochmal heute auf
einer pressekonferenz davon wie wichtig
es ist die hygiene konzepte in
pflegeheimen und in altenheimen
tatsächlich zu befolgen die
möglicherweise auch noch weiter zu
verschärfen
wir hören kurz rein heute einmal mehr
deutlich über 400 todesfälle zu beklagen
innerhalb von 24 stunden auf grund von
kogit 19
und wir beschäftigen uns dieser tage
viel mit der frage wie wir weihnachten
verbringen
diese menschen werden weihnachten gar
nicht mehr erleben und ihre angehörigen
werden trauern
und darum geht es eben jahr vor allem
mit den maßnahmen und mit unserem
hinweis an uns alle ich nehme mich da
gar nicht aus an uns alle als
bürgerinnen und bürger weiterhin
aufeinander aufzupassen auch nach diesen
vielen monaten auch nach diesem nicht
leichten wochen
weiterhin alles zu tun auch durch
kontakt reduzierung durch die aha regeln
dass wir die infektionszahlen
unterbringen in einem land wie unserem
das eben so ist durchschnittsalter hat
an so und anteil auf einer älteren
bevölkerung hat und auch vorerkrankungen
hat das wir 27 millionen menschen etwa
eben in der definition von risikogruppe
auch haben führen steigende
infektionszahlen zeitversetzt auch
zuhören intensiv zahlen und todesfällen
es lässt sich nicht trennen auch wenn
das einige in der diskussion immer
wieder versuchen zu trennen und ich
finde
deswegen ist eben wichtig dass wir schon
vorne ansetzen nämlich beim reduzieren
der infektionszahlen mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bild schau dir
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren